i have some exciting news i'd like to
share with you uh
i uh early this morning i was
texting back and forth with someone i
was interested in uh potentially being
my vice president when i run this person
uh texted me and said i want to uh
congratulate you and you have my vote
and
very lovely conversation and i said um
how would you feel about being my vice
president and you know what he said
done done
done in other words i'm in
and it's exciting
and who is it you're gonna tell us or
not well and i'll tell you how great uh
this vice presidential pick is he said
to me you know i'm in but uh you know
i'm another a white male
and i said you know i i appreciate you
saying that but i believe you'll be such
an asset to the ticket that i think
people will understand well have you
given this
great consideration
i gave it almost as much consideration
as i did putting my hat in the ring
almost none
he was the first person i asked and he
said yes so my search is
over we're gonna straighten things out
and with my new vice president who i
like to announce
he uh he told me he wants in
i was shocked i think he should be live
when you uh make this i don't
i don't think he wants to be bothered
he's actually um
he's actually shooting a movie right now
as we speak
oh it's another uh
well but don't talk so soon this guy's
gonna bring in the female vote like you
wouldn't believe
my vice president
vice president bradley cooper i know it
sent chills yeah i know it sent chills
up your spot get out of here he said he
wants to be vice president that's right
i know i know you know what he's saying
yesterday
no
i told him i'm announcing it today
i'm locking him in
he said he's done he wants it and it's
gonna be he's going to be my vice
president who's going to take over the
government when you step down
bradley cooper oh he's not going to
going to want to go back to hollywood
no
no he wants it well let me just say one
thing uh you know when ronald reagan
decided to run for president they were
like you know that's a guy who acted
with a chimp
right
and now we're gonna have a guy who's
played a raccoon
that's right and he's terrific and he he
didn't even he's a great record he's a
real patriot and a great raccoon that's
our campaign
[Laughter]